Gamers said it couldn't be done
No one's ever played this game Felix
you're crazy to do it
I don't care.
ok?
it's gamer week god damn it
and this is the days where dreams come true.
today we're playing bee movie game
Bee Movie Game!
that's the title of this game
it didn't take long for me to run out of games to play did it?
why am i playing this?
cuz i CAN.
alright?
let's just frickin go!
oh my god what is that?
*juanette whuung?*
so that's a chinese bee?
cool
hello again new hive city we're here again with a very special guest
oh god i have to figure out the controls
what's A?
it's an emulator
oh I think I figured it out. ok
of course it is now barry tell us about your adventure.
you like.... bees?
ok.
loading. bzzz
I like that
I like that. This game has attention to detail goddamn it
"bzz."
oh god did I break it?no
awwwwwww.....
that sucks
let's try that again
yyeeah! alright
too much epicness for this game apparently
that's fine! I don't mind redoing all of that!
vicarious visions what have they done
they made crash bandicoot
they made destiny 2
alright let's do a save slate
here we go gamers
pleasepleasepleasepleasepleasepleaseplesase please
PLEASE.
alright gamers
here we goooo
here we freaking go gamers
Adam. now that you co-congraduations (??)
can't read.
you want to go with adam? noo
get outta my way h8rs
I'm playin bee movie!
it's gaming week
excuse me bae!?
haha
gaming wEEeek!!
smash like and buy all the merch for gam-- alright can't go there
ay watcha where youre goin!
thats what they-- that's a line from the film
"my sweater is ralph lauren"
woah! he does cool animation if you don't play
see that's attention to detail
that I expect from creators of bee movie.
excuse me.
"can i help u with something?"
nope guess not.